long feet ahead for Brock Nelson matched up
quickly with Quinn Hughes who takes the puck
away and he conuts Captain moves it along for
Conor Garland on the right side Bluer driving
Garland shooting no problem there for sroi
well this is going to hurt him ni for sure
having him back now they can rely on for big
minutes is Luger drives to the net the puck
squirts through the crease and out the other
side that be a a little bit good in your own
Zone they're going to have to be very good in
their own Zone orat floats it to the goal and
it's grabbed by Casey the Smith saw Romanov there
right off the face off it's Paul Mary turning and
shooting and a save made by Smith we've seen buch
Islander Defenders chased behind the net or manov
stopped and stayed in front of the net and I guess
what you always say didn't leave good ice for bad
ice that's exactly right and that's something
that apparently they worked on in practice over
the last little while angal driving to the post
put it on goal stop by Smith when your team is
playing well on winning a lot of hockey games
here's Brock Nelson to the FR and it's sa by
the Smith as he takes one away from angal Brock
Nelson little spinorama play right on the Stick
Of angal Slides it along the ice and I talk about
it all had some opportunities though Pierre Ang
Bal actually has more shots in this game than the
entire kuu team to this point Garland got in put
a shot Off The Stick of sokia Pou near the board
gooier broke his stick Pou able to hang on that
one and force it across for doson he'll t one up
save from the Smith sprays to the boards now it's
angal with Quinn Hughes chasing him down to the
[Applause] corner out it's to kusco shoveled on
goal sroa knocked it down Ang ball right there
with suer swept away from danger and now barzel
finds the mice behind the net now he turns the
Jets off barzel on the move barzel around the
corner with a shot that didn't miss by much J to
see the santis just got out of there in a hurry
the Smith excuse me got out of there in a hurry
took away the Garland put it in his SK trying to
get some help Garland came off the wall with it
Conor Garland off the outside of the post Luger
to Garland again that one hit AO barels out of
the box as sidorov comes in in a hurry Nikita
zadorov circling the net for heroni with a blast
spuck by cikas and he's struggling to get back up
centering feed MF kicked out by croen heroic
scores that was a bad bounce I'm pretty sure
brenon we'll get another look that might have
went off Cal inadvertently into the net and
that cikas might have been able to get into place
if he he's limping off the ice so well here's the
block and down goes Casey cikas and I mean you
can see that he's hurting referees aren look at
he's still down on the ice referees still haven't
done anything and take a look to see where this
guy who this goes off of I I could be wrong with
there guys that's just a really good shot off the
off the [Applause] crossbar Ashville Minnesota
Winnipeg Chicago through the central as a h
shot G through for a save from soken Brock besser
has 25 goals this season here's a centering feed
the shot went off the skate of ranov and then
the puck loses the side of the net shot wide a
strange sequence there GCKA left the zone and then
came flying back in and Quinn Hughes gets free and
scores Quinn Hughes across the slot traffic in
front of sokin and the Deep pair of veronic and
Hughes have given the Canucks a two nothing lead
well that all starts with the battle right kucks
just maintain control a lot of movement in there
and you can see where the Islanders have a little
issue of who to take right now as everybody's
kind of standing around not sure and Hughes just
moves right to the middle and soken is screened
as Noah doson is right in the middle of the ice
Miller just zinged it over the glass
barzel with the steel he's got Paul Mar
in a two-on one Paul Mary Save rebound
taken out of the air by Carson Susi two
onone with Matt barzel the Smith
the save the lead still two for
Vancouver this is grabed by Hughes and then heric
to the front of the net a lot of traffic there
Adam pelet could get away from the pile two on one
down low Pon AC off and they score pson to Miller
and back again and a turnover Deep In The Islander
Zone leads to the third goal for Vancouver yeah
just good hard work and never giving up on the
puck and Miller besser and Patterson eventually
scores the goal they just attacked good play in
the in the area there there's pelic and and and
he just stops skating for a second and then the
good hard work and look at this play right here
one two three I mean Miller maybe could have put
the puck in now there little little slash on the
hands but no not called and look at the move by
Pon and then just back and forth as Mayfield's
not able to protect that that pass coming back
across here's Thompson for barzel Paul Mary fell
down gets back up they get him the puck Paul Mary
and barzel again Paul Mary backand across they
score Paul Mary behind the back to Brock Nelson
a power play goal and now they wanted to set it
up right off the bat as soon as they got control
Paul Mary changes the angle of the of the pass
you can see the high stick on Horvat but watch
barzel is going to move up Paul Mary down low
going to make this pass he's looking looking oh
doesn't work okay let's try it again barza Waits
and then changes the angle and able to get it
through the top of the crease and man alive do
Brock Nelson snap this one he doesn't make any
mistake in that area and that's just a huge goal
for for the for the Islanders you think Kyle P
neander got 11 A2 a year guess it's whatever the
budget can afford right P's going to be in that
neighborhood is the restrict free agent at the
end of the year here's Tyler Myers Myers winds
fires and scores Tyler Meyers just blows one
through sokin and it's a 4-1 conu lead I I think
sokin thinks he should have had that Brendan he
just just his reaction and then the Islanders
in on the four check three Islanders there tra
and that's where they get a get a problem Myers
just let that thing go I went in between the the
blocker right and you watch Adam pelic here he
doesn't want to disrupt dilia you put your stick
in there you're going to make it harder so he gets
it out of the way for good reason and Myers just
overpowers him that's that's a tough goal to give
up you mention to Butch I might have been the best
save and it wasn't by the goalie they've adjusted
the shots back to 18 for the Islanders and they
had 11 of those 18 shots in the first period just
four in the second and three so far here in the
third Nelson [Applause] scores Nelson's got his
second tonight it's a 4-2 hockey game late in the
third sling that one didn't he and just get it
in deep when the hos get in on the check which
you can't say happened all that often and but
they were able to come up with a loose Puck and
Brock Nelson just wondering what can he do with
it he just hangs on to it and he just whips a
shot look at the sling there and man alive that
a good shot well the Islanders a little hope a
little hope now you're talking about pulling
the go a ro into the bench extra attacker is
Paul Mary Anders Lee comes on in place of Paso
as barzel carries the puck oh he turn it over
Dakota Joshua fires it into the empty net from
his own Blue Line oh takes the drama out of it
pretty quick it's 5-2 Vancouver after the empty
n from Dakota Joshua take another look and see
where barzel see if he was going left yeah
he was he was trying to make a pass and to
Anders Lee I think you got to get it in brenon
I think you got to make sure you get it in and
go to work because if you do turn it over like
Matt did uh then is a problem so I I think you
have to get in nobody you thought they'd be this
good and you're right the Flyers are better than
whatever oh late here Matt Martin Dakota Joshua
having a couple of words at the horn linman
quickly intervene and the referees make sure
the Canucks bench doesn't come join in on this